being well prepared is a necessity
during a time like this
and that includes making sure your
vehicle is ready to take on
whatever adventure is next subaru of las
vegas has you covered
[Applause]
so when you buy a new subaru you have
the original factory
warranty that's a three year 36 plan and
your
powertrain is usually covered for five
years and 60 thousand miles
a lot of people don't consider though
that after those warranties expire
how are they going to have those
components covered
and not just the engine and the
transmission and the all-wheel drive
but also like for instance air
conditioning high-tech features you know
just the center stack alone where your
radio is
that's two thousand dollars if you have
to replace it because it also includes a
lot of components for the
air conditioning in the heating system
or the headlights
headlight unit is a thousand dollars to
replace a lot of people don't realize
the high-tech nature of all these
components
make them very expensive and that's why
the subaru added security plan
is so worthwhile i like to go right to
the gold plus plan because the gold plus
is going to cover all of your major
components and it
is most like the original factory
warranty
in the fact that it covers all of your
high-tech electronics
it covers mechanical it'll cover um
just i mean it literally is almost
a bumper to bumper extended service plan
you know there are a few exceptions but
it is an amazing plan and you can get it
in different lengths in other words you
can get a five year sixty thousand mile
plan you can get
a seven one hundred you can get an eight
ten year plan all the plans
include towing allowance rental
allowance and the gold plus plan
even includes trip interruption which if
you're out somewhere
out away from home and you have to have
your vehicle worked on
they will help pay for your incidentals
your room and board
during the time that you are without
your vehicle also subaru has some
excellent maintenance plans that are in
addition to the
added security plan and the maintenance
will cover your oil changes it'll cover
tire rotations
it'll cover the the routine maintenance
items and
those also are available in two and
three and four year plans
so we have a another product called the
subaru equity shield and the equity
shield is a great plan
to put on your vehicle when you purchase
it and those aren't new or used vehicles
and it will cover basically tire dent
ding it'll it'll cover
some of the things if you lose your keys
it covers the replacement
and the reprogramming of a brand new set
of keys and so that is the equity shield
plan
and it is a great thing to have and
typical subaru ownership
is a long time people drive their
subarus and they typically will hand
them down to family members
because they are such a long lasting
product and
so that's why these extra coverages are
a great
purchase check out subaru of las vegas
on roy horn way call 702-495-2100 or
visit subaru
of lasvegas.com and they have a special
for you
the february true love event offers zero
percent apr financing
on select 2021 models for well-qualified
buyers
las vegas now will be right